alright alright we're doing [ __ ]
Deadpool hold your [ __ ] horses geez
look we weren't gonna [ __ ] - dead bull
from the same actor in studio
responsible for this comes the film that
might finally let us forgive them for
this
Deadpool captain Deadpool suit up for
the r-rated film that you had to be 17
to see but 16 to fully appreciate
hashtag drive-in foxes hugely successful
comic book movie that never would have
been made if someone behind the scenes
didn't fearlessly leaked the test
footage and even then still never would
have been made if an said and demanded
Fox grow up here and released the entire
movie watch as this accidental hit out
grossed Thor Captain America the amazing
spider-man guardians of the galaxy every
x-men movie and Batman V Superman likely
prompting a new wave of all rated
superhero films
so when Aquaman starts throwing out
sperm whale jokes you know who to thank
holy crap Deadpool
no it's Rhythm Nation era Janet Jackson
yeah a [ __ ] Deadpool Wow
you're showing up in your own honest
trailer that is so meta well it's kind
of my thing shall we let's do this
meet Wade Wilson a pansexual hit man
with a heart of gold and his fiancee
Vanessa okay
escort with a heart of gold when cancer
sends wade into Weapon X is non-union
equivalent he'll turn into Deadpool a
wisecracking indestructible psychopath
who will do anything to get his fiancee
back except talk to her which would have
been way too easy
causing the movie to end in like 20
minutes instead follow along on Ryan
Reynolds epic quest to look like Ryan
Reynolds again as this immortal Tucker
max battles villains that pose no real
threat to him bowl of my signature both
wall breaking I think Ryan Reynolds got
this far and a superior acting method
90s pop culture references nothing
compares to you XI Nader
and more dick jokes than you can shake a
sack full of dicks at
in what feels like a really expensive
longer episode of Family Guy
wait-wait-wait-wait-wait which which
which season a Family Guy are we talking
about let's say fourth oh okay I can
take that so prepare for a story that
much like its hero wants to have it both
ways
where they will beautifully make fun of
all the superhero genre cliches super er
landing while giving you the same old
conventional love story and
by-the-numbers revenge but we've seen a
million times before whoa whoa all
simmer down there big boy by the numbers
the [ __ ] is that supposed to mean hey I
said I liked it in the beginning I think
it's fair to point out some flaws - Oh
fair do you think I give a moist bag of
soggy Flint about fare Deadpool is the
highest-grossing r-rated movie of all
time
except for Jesus uh everyone is suck he
might know and you sure should be too
you back ass twaddle [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
is with these beeps you know kids watch
these videos mr. pool kids [ __ ] love
it when I curse bag turbo boner man it
felt good look the only reason I'm even
here is to promote Deadpool which is now
out on blu-ray and DVD blah blah blah
blah blah like anyone still buys those
glorified thing drink coasters so let's
be real honest trailer guy I'm Way too
big of a deal to be slumming it in some
played out webseries yeah commenters do
say we're not as funny as we used to be
now comedians in cars getting coffee
that's a show I should do hey hey hey
can I listen to you do the honest names
I love that part honest names know the
bit you do at the end of your videos
that we quote borrowed for our opening
credits well at least you're admitting
it let me show you how it's done great
just make it snappy I have to crank out
some Deadpool Reax videos now those
brothers aren't suing people anymore
starring freaking the streets put a
freak in the sheets yeah coughs strung
off a TJ Miller type teenage mutant
negasonic Stanley in between movies and
oh oh oh oh can I do this one sure it's
all yours and
as the fetid testicle wrestler fan even
Wilder oh that went good Ferris Bueller
jerks off oh I see what you did there
good one great but don't ask me to do
this again for Deadpool too I'm serious
okay
do you have Wolverines number of agents
yes I do I've got it my phone under the
name Jean Valjean can you give it to me
now be sure to subscribe for more honest
trailers thanks again to Deadpool for
slumming it up in our dumb internet
video to hear about how he pulled this
off and see some bonus Deadpool jokes
that didn't make the final cut click the
box to the right to check out our honest
commentaries on screen junkies plies and
be sure to click the other box to see
the Russo brothers give their honest
reaction to our Winter Soldier honest
trailer now let's get to the only reason
you're still listening hastily typed
user comments the Fitnessgram Pacer test
is a multi-stage aerobic capacity test I
like the new Ghostbusters trailer I
drink and I know things
mission report December 16 1991 longing
Rusted 17 day break furnace 9 benign
homecoming 1 freight car time to bake
the chimi qingcheng cos